dude this is the coolest remote because
i can do
black screen it's awesome hi guys
you hi guys all right good cool you guys
are awake fantastic
i'm going to talk to you guys about
monitoring mysql with opentsdb
um i forgot to change percona live 2013
to sfmysql
august 15th august 13th wow go home jeff
um so sorry about that but yes my name
is jeffrey anderson i
am a dba
excuse me i am a database operations
engineer at box which is a fancy way of
calling myself a database administrator
looks really cool on your business cards
so but uh
my my day-to-day is tooling and
administration for mysql and hbase i'm
actually our hbase lead
at box as well which is maybe part of
the reason that we
enjoy obtsd so much because it also runs
in hbase
and i also do this bi-weekly google
hangout called db hangouts
this was something that we started up
after mysql connect last year every two
weeks get a bunch of dbas on a google
hangout we kind of talk about
databasy things um and it started as a
small thing and it's gotten pretty
popular and i'd encourage you guys to
check it out and watch some of the
youtube videos that we've recorded
so uh disclaimer i do have to talk about
my company
which is actually a pretty fun place to
work and if you
are looking for a job please talk to me
after the meetup
but um yeah what box does is we are a
file uh storage platform uh primarily
targeted at enterprises
and so many you guys are probably
familiar with products like dropbox
google drive
box same thing um i mean we we focus
more on enterprise but we also
uh work for the small business and for
users as well and we have a very feature
rip
feature rich application uh web
application so if you haven't
used it before i'd encourage you to
check it out you know see if you like it
see what you like
what you don't like maybe and definitely
be vocal about it
cool so let's talk about the situation
because i'm here to talk about
monitoring
um so you guys are dbas so you probably
use percona monitoring plugins
i hope or something you know that's just
around there same thing
you know a bunch of cacti plugins a
bunch of nagios plugins and you might
even have your own nagios checks that
you've added you know things that come
up
that are really weird like long running
queries happen
maybe your mysql config changes for some
reason that's what this one is here
maybe a dba changed a variable and
didn't store it and so a server is
running differently than everyone else
um things that happen so you add more
nagios checks to find these right
or maybe you use some other system
that's not nagios but again you still
you're trying to find you know as more
edge cases happen and things that take
your site down
or just a server maybe that'd be good
too you add stuff for it
and you probably use procona toolkit or
mysql utilities from
oracle or any other slew of just mysql
toolkit kind of stuff
and you know you'll be using maybe for
kind of tool kit and you just use stock
so you can look at your servers and
figure out what they're doing when they
get a little upset
um you know maybe you're gonna look at
poor man's profiler
and use that to try and figure out
what's happening to a server that's in a
real bad state
and maybe you're just running pt query
digest occasionally to see what the heck
is actually going into your server
you know some really weird queries
showing up a lot you need to know that
they're there
but then you get a lot of servers and so
you have cacti graphs that look like
this and
you just um i can't even count how many
problems might be here and it's just a
nightmare and
after staring at this for a while maybe
you don't have a knock team maybe you're
one or
one of one dba or one of three dbas and
this just turns into
a hilarious first world problem um at
least i like to think it's a funny first
world problem maybe it's not but you
know there's a lot of servers and
it's really exhausting to look at all of
them and you know this happens when you
start you know you go from one instance
of mysql production to
10 and you need to start caring about
more of them and less about individual
services potentially
so this is where opentsdb comes into the
picture
and opentsdb is a distributed
scalable time series database it was
created excuse me it runs on hbase and
it was created by benoit sigour
and so a box the way we have it set up
we have our hbase cluster
we throw the time series daemons from
opentsdb
we have clusters of them one for storing
data and one for actual interactive
querying
we put an ha proxy layer in front of
that so that we can round robin through
them without causing you know major
pain or bottlenecks and then you have
your database and maybe a front end
and okay that's a joke right because
you're gonna have a lot of databases and
a lot of front ends
cool so and then you'll have your laptop
because you actually need you actually
care about the data that you're probably
collecting and want to look at it and
know that things are going well or going
poor um so your servers will be pushing
metrics into this pipeline
um and then your your laptop or your
whatever interface you're using you're
going to hit the open tsd
api to get the data out um so i mean
why would you even care about opentsdb
like you've got cacti and everything
already why should you go through the
pain to like set up hbase and
set up this whole other system and
pipeline and well
it's fast i can't even begin to tell you
how fast this stuff is
it's very easy to scale if it gets slow
add more servers like that's that's it's
literally that's all you do
you stand up more servers if you've
puppeted this or if you have chef or cf
engine
once you've got your configs figured out
you just add more servers and put the
config on them you're good to go
it's very very easy to populate and by
this i mean it's very easy to put
metrics and collect
collect metrics and put them into the
system and
lastly it's definitely very easy to
query and i'll show you some examples of
like just querying the interface to get
some data out of it
so let's talk about collecting data
because you guys are
operations folks probably you probably
care about collecting data a whole bunch
because you really want to know what's
happening so since this is a mysql
meetup we're going to write a collector
from mysql
nice little shell script just you know
show global status we just want to know
what the server is doing
and for each of those we're going to put
we're going to print out a print out all
the
uh counters that we get back with a
special prefix and we're just going to
use mysql dot
um and so i'll just show you the output
of this real quick
so you effectively get everything from
show global status mysql dot
that variable uh you dump a timestamp
and then the value that you got back
and the last thing is tags and so just
to point out real quick
this is going to be your metric name the
thing that you get for your actual
counters
the timestamp of when it happened the
value for it and then
key value tags and you can have as many
of those as you want
up to seven i think right now is what
it's hard-coded in the server but you
can have multiple tags
and these help you for identifying and
looking at servers and aggregate in
different ways and i'll show you this a
little more
in the interface in a moment excuse me
so you want to get these metrics into
opentsd you could set up a cron
that just pipes just uses netcat and
throws them into the server it
usually runs on four two four two but
don't don't do this this this is kind of
janky and gross and
i'm just gonna say you should feel bad
if you do this let me just prefix it
that way
there's this really cool tool called t
collector it's a data collection
framework for opentsdb it was written by
the authors of opentsdb
and it's a python demon that you can set
up and will just kind of manage data
collection for you
and you just hand it stuff to do data
collection with so if you were to take t
collector and throw it on your database
server
you'd kind of get a directory structure
like this and the thing you care about
most is this collector's directory
because under here there's a series of
other directories and these are actually
intervals and seconds that you should
run a specific collector
so things on the xero directory you
always want those to run those are
probably collectors that need to
maintain some sort of state
and they'll just do a sleep for like
maybe 30 seconds while they're
collecting information
then you have the 15 second ones in this
case df stat is a disc free collector
just collects information about free
space on the host
uh the mysql collector let's run it
every 30 seconds because that's twice
the granularity we get from cacti
bam and then the last one is one that we
wrote at box
it's called pttcp model it actually
simply uses the percona toolkit tcp
model script
which is actually no longer in bacona
tool we had to go
back port it when we upgraded and it
went away this collector broke pretty
horribly
but i'll show you what we use this for
this is actually a really cool collector
we've got too
so let's talk about querying data you've
got your data in there
you're running t collector it's shipping
all of your metrics from all of your
servers
um so here's the interface it's a little
washed out but
so i'm sorry about that but um
it's uh it's very clearly designed by an
engineer
yep don't be fooled it is actually
extremely powerful
and so let's say i wanted to look at
percent idle cpu on my databases
and so i'm actually there's actually
three time series plotted here and the
reason
is because of this bad boy or these two
here so these are the tags
that you had so in the collector example
i showed you just had host equals
well you can have other tags like maybe
you have a server type tag
and so in this case i'm actually
plotting all application databases
and another tag that we have is cluster
so this
if you throw an asterisk in there it
breaks out and plots
every possible value for that metric uh
and it just draws an individual time
series
so this actually draws every cluster
that we have and so
i'm not you know it doesn't take an
expert to realize that
that kind of step function looks wrong
doesn't you know you should
should be a nice normal pattern over a
period of time so that something's up
with that
and this is actually our sharded
database cluster so what we can do
is plug shard into the cluster tag and
now we have only the shard databases and
the other thing is we throw an asterisk
into the host tag
so that it plots all the hosts by
default and now you can see there's very
clearly an outlier which is
server 22 in this graph everyone else is
kind of doing fine
not using too much cpu server 22 is like
just
chewing through cpu and then magically
recovers and then chews through it again
it's really weird behavior
so we can put server 22 in that host
field so we have only that on the graph
just to kind of clean it up and get a
nice easy thing to look at
and then what we can do this isn't
enough information for us to figure out
the problem and so this
the problem with cacti that i found was
if a graph doesn't have
all the metrics you care about in it you
have to sit there and kind of look at
one
and look at the other and see if the
time matches up with open tsd
we're just going to add another metric
and so i punch in threads connected
for server 22 and now you see this kind
of thing where as threads
the number of connected threads on this
server rises the load or
the idle cpu goes down so the load on
the machine is going up it's doing more
work as more threads connect
and the other thing i did here is check
this right axis box so all threads
connected will be on the right y-axis
and the percent idle will be on the left
and so this allows you to mix and match
metrics you know maybe their y-axis
might clapper each other
you can split them apart so that you can
look at them both and see the nice step
functions kind of correlate
and so in this case this was actually a
problem we had a really nasty query get
onto production
after a code push and we have a we run
pt kill against all of our database
servers as a demon
so it'll go in there if it finds long
queries it beats them and it whacks them
and we have it to kill anyone else who's
following that so
the thing we have here is queries are
stacking up and then we start whacking
all the queries and that's why it
recovers
and goes up again but we were able to
find the problematic query because of
this pretty quickly and resolve it
so now let's say i want to get a closer
look and get a better time
line because i have to do a postmortem
you just click and drag with your mouse
you know and it'll automatically just
zoom you in and now you've got a much
closer view we can see this happened
around 7 45 a.m
and the best part is i can just copy
paste the url
and send it to somebody so they can see
the exact thing i'm looking at now after
all that i'm you know digging i did
copy paste and throw it at another
person to look at too
and as you can see i mean this it's
literally the start and end times
the metric that i plopped in and all the
other information
from our just from our digging is right
in the url so it's very easy to share
um and since we're ops people we also
like just raw data you know maybe we
don't want to look at that ugly gnu plot
graph
that's fine okay you can also get the
raw data and by getting raw data you can
do some really cool things like build a
custom interface that does
week-over-week graphs
and allows you to easily find problems
and do anomaly detection
and so this is actually a snapshot of
our newest tool that we open source it's
called status wolf
and the beauty of this is it allows us
to build dashboards we can plug in all
of our open tsdb information
we can easily draw week over week graphs
and we also our vp of techops had built
an anomaly detection
model that we can put in here too and so
they'll build a confidence model of data
over the
like last three weeks of data and
highlight outliers in the graph
which is really really cool for finding
problems status wolf i'll have links at
the end to
show you for sure um and so currently it
only works with opentsdb but
i think we've we've tried our best to
engineer the code so you could arguably
plug it into other monitoring tools
to get the data out so i'd encourage you
to check it out on github pull a copy
file issues and i'll talk more about it
at the end of the presentation and
if you guys want to know more but that
api call
it's pretty much the same as the web
front end call the difference is
it's uh you hit slash q and you throw
ascii at the end
and you get the raw data back and you
can cut it up with awk or you know
any other tool of your choosing and you
can even write your own code to kind of
parse metrics and do fun things with
them on the fly
so how do we leverage open tsd from
mysql
um well some of the stuff we use at box
we
we we use procona so we have user
statistics
as an extension so we have that enabled
on all of our servers and we collect the
information that you can get from show
on user underscore statistics
and so we were just kind of throwing
these things into opentsdb initially to
see
what kind of data do we have available
that we can look at and
honestly like it's become really really
powerful for various things
in the case of user stats this gives us
kind of a poor man's audit report
we can actually look at you know how
many times a specific user
issued a select statement or how many
failed logins they might have had
and so this allows us to get a little
more insight into the servers where you
might have to get a commercial plug-in
to start with
another one we have is the table
statistics uh
extension that's impercona we just
collect this information and this allows
us to look at information around
uh index changes table changes and
aggregate
and you can also break it out by table
and by schema and so
with the way we have our environment set
up it makes it very easy to figure out
do we have a hot database schema on a
single instance of mysql
this can allow us to track that down
and then the other one we have is table
information from information schema
and you can actually get this by just
running this query and so we run this
query every
30 minutes i think and dump the data
into opentsdb because this can be a
little expensive you're kind of
calculating the size of the tables and
all this other stuff that
is a little invasive but getting it
periodically allows us to get
some very basic graphene around table
growth over time
so we don't have to run it one off one
at a time like we just have this
information available to us
and it's allowed us to write other tools
for capacity modeling so we can look at
you know the growth
of records growth of tables over time
number of records in them
and we can also look at growth of the
data files over time and kind of gauge
you know
in two weeks we're going to need a whole
lot more servers to sustain some growth
that we have
and last but not least was that tcp
model collector i was talking about
um that actually allows us to get query
throughput information so we can see if
a mysql server starts doing less work
than it normally does and this has been
very valuable for tracking down some
hard
to find issues that are normally kind of
masked by other things
um but if you see that query throughput
starts going down
but the server still seems okay then
maybe your queries are taking longer or
there's something
making them get stuck in the server so
this is a nice early indicator for that
and we actually we threw our collector
up on our github account too if you want
to grab a copy of it check it out
it's a beautiful collector it's a shell
script that runs tcp done for 10 seconds
kills it and then ships the data got out
of it
i never thought i would be proud of
saying that we run tcp done for 10
seconds in an automated thing
it's a little janky feeling but it
actually works very well we've run it
for over a year now
so and then there's other common metrics
that you can watch you know
any of the mysql status counters maybe
that are you know i didn't talk about
already you know qps is a big one you're
going to want to watch on your servers
make sure it's you know got a nice
make sure there's not a sudden drop in
that or something
number of threads that are connected to
the server you know there's nothing
worse than getting an alert saying
you're
you've chewed through all of your
available connections on the server it'd
be nice to see that if there's a ramp up
that you can
help avoid temp tables on disk that's a
good indicator of
you know queries that might need
optimization you know if you remove
those temp tables you can run faster
and just other things along those lines
and then there's various service
statistics so you know that's all the
mysql specific stuff
then you want to look at like maybe your
idle cpu or how much work it's doing on
i o uh free disk space that you have and
like i said a second ago i o utilization
and network traffic's the other big one
maybe you get a flood
of really big packets all of a sudden
it'd be nice to know that might be the
cause of a problem
um so other future collectors and so
these are the ones that we haven't built
yet but we've been
thinking about it'd be nice to get some
of our pt query digest stuff
into opentsdb um we kind of shelved this
one for a while because
mysql is in a pretty good state for us
and we had other
higher priority things to do but i mean
we
run pt query digest regularly on all of
our servers we collect about
we sample about one percent of queries
on all of our production machines
and do a digest on them and we ship that
to a tool that we wrote called
anemometer
also available on github if you guys
want to check it out and it allows us to
look
at the query digest information we got
back in a graphical format
and identify outliers through there and
so i could see us
shipping some of that data to opentsdv
to save us on the graphene in our own
interface
data that you can get out of show
engineer db status and of course this is
information that should be counters but
it isn't right now
um so maybe there's some other stuff we
can kind of grip out of there we haven't
really
thought to dig too deeply because again
we're pretty content where we are and
i mean we'll just see as we go and then
any other stuff that might be in
performance scheme on 5.6 because a
whole slew of new things including
query statistics process list
information and background thread
information
and so just being able to access all
that stuff and throw it into opentsdb
over time would make it very easy to
look at this stuff
you know when you have issues and being
able to correlate problems before
so how does this change things for for
you you know you're setting up this new
monitoring tool
um well you're going to collect all of
the data
like all of it you know you're going to
retain all the granularity
you know more than a minute hopefully
and you're going to find
all the problems and if you don't find
them someone else will because
once they learn how to use the tool
they're going to realize how much easier
it is to discover things
uh so in all seriousness though um the
the big things that you get with
opentsdp
is it's very easy to see aggregate
graphs so once you get to a point where
you have a lot of servers it's very easy
to see them
just kind of lumped as a group and if
you want you can try
you can dig down and find the outliers
too it's very easy to build the graphs
on the fly
that's actually one of the best parts of
it you know one of the biggest hangouts
i have with cacti
is creating graphs for it is a real
chore i'm not sure if any of you have
had to do it
and if you do you are a superstar
um and you should stop doing that and
use up tsp instead
you maintain full granularity forever
forever because it's not using rrds
it doesn't auto down sample that data is
perfect granularity until you delete it
consciously like it will stay there
forever at full granularity there's no
auto down sampling
and you can do api requests to get the
raw data you don't want the interface
and you can use that to build your own
fun tools and whatnot
and the other cool thing is you can do
cluster-wide kind of checks
so there's a nagios check or nagios
plug-in they row called check tsd that
you just say here's an open tsdb server
here's a metric
and kind of give it like thresholds to
look at and that way instead of having
to do some weird stuff where you auto
aggregate
stats from your servers to do a check on
them you can
easily just get it out of opentsdv and
it also means you can start moving away
from individual server
checks that just go off all the time
when you get more servers and have you
know you only care if your app
maybe your application cluster is
unhealthy and unhealthy is defined by
some some way the graphs look instead of
if one out of 100 servers has a problem
you probably don't care
if half of them have a problem you do
and it's nicer to get one page instead
of 50.
so challenges that you might see
switching and
this is just our experience at box the
challenges we had switching
uh the big one was aggregates were the
default you know when we set up up in
tstb we were at the kind of the point
where we were going from like a
maybe a three instance production setup
to a lot more
um and just trying to get used to the
fact that you don't look at an
individual host you have to look at
everyone
and if one server has a problem it's not
that big of a deal
mouse zooming was actually a big problem
too because that didn't exist
i mean if you guys use cacti you know
you look at a cacti graph you zoom
and you have your new cacti graph that
you zoomed in on opentsdb didn't have
that
um i wrote a patch for it one night and
it
like everyone started using opentdsb the
next day like that was the biggest
problem that we found
was not being able to easily zoom in on
graphs and once that was there it became
the
very useful tool um auto suggests for
the metrics
it's a little still a little flaky um
we actually we built a custom tool that
just dumps all the metrics out of the
server
on a light center it's a cron job that
runs every 15 minutes
writes them into a json file and then we
have a nice interface that just exposes
that
but i i believe the auto suggestion
problem
i'm going to put that quotes is actually
severely improved in the news version of
opentsdb
we're currently running an older version
of one dot
something i actually don't know i didn't
i didn't manage it
but they just announced the release
candidate for 2.0
in the past few weeks so i know this was
a big thing that was getting fixed
the graphs aren't pretty in quotes we
heard this a lot from uh
managers managers as the bosses of the
boss of the boss
up up the ladder right you would you
would want to say oh we've got this
really cool graph that shows how the
database servers have been growing over
time and we can use it for our capacity
planning
and you hand it to the higher up and he
looks and he's like this this is really
ugly
this is like disgusting why are the
lines all jaggedy and gross
so we patched that too and that's
that's actually if you were to get open
ts-tv
there might be a fire guys
i feel like it's a rave now for my talk
but um yeah so there is an option
in the interface now you can check it
and it'll smooth out the graph so they
don't look as spiky
which is nice to send up hmm
i actually don't know
they do a little but yeah it uses a new
plot to draw the graphs under the hood
um where's the other one oh migrating
from our proof of concept
so when we first had opentsdb setup we
had
one host in each of our data centers um
and that was running an hbase cluster
which is funny to run a cluster on a
single machine
an opentsdv setup and a few other things
and we we had t collector set up in a
few places and we're shipping metrics
but no one really used it no one really
looked at it it was just kind of
collecting and we were trying to get
people to start using it because
we were realizing the value and once
that mouse zoom patch hit
our single node fell over the next day
and we could never keep it up and
running because everyone just
constantly started using it and that's
when we learned
my word of advice to you guys have at
least three nodes i'd say if you can
just spring for five nodes
you know have an actual cluster kind of
thing so you can kind of tolerate burst
traffic
um and i mean you you can run this in
amazon if you want to as well like
you can you just need multiple nodes
they don't you don't want one beefy node
you want multiple
smaller nodes they can be crappy even um
and uh definitely the other one was uh
data
data pruning might be required we hit a
point where we filled up our disk on the
opentsdb cluster the initial one we set
up
and uh we had to go back and trim it
down so we only kept three months of
data because we were just filling it so
aggressively
and i mean when you think about it like
the mysql collector there's like 300
status counters
and if you have 300 counters you know
maybe 50
servers are reporting them and you know
once you add them up
it adds up very quickly you know and
there's a whole slew of things that are
in there
yes it depends
and i'll give you a few more numbers i
actually didn't get disc information but
i
i might have a ballpark i can give you
so
let me talk about some quick numbers for
open to be a box
um we currently record 29 577 metrics
um 95 tag keys
so these were the things like host
cluster we only have 95 of those but we
have over 5 million possible values for
those
so the reason you really want to use
tags
is it allows you to have a strictly
defined set of metrics and then the tags
allow you to do
aggregation by default and drill down
afterwards um
we have a lot of servers reporting in um
i i don't even know how many
but uh to give you a rough estimate of
storage
the last time i looked at our opentsdb
store hbase cluster
i think it was around 20 terabytes maybe
take um it's about a year of data so
it fills up pretty quickly i know we had
to go back and
delete a lot of stuff and we're actually
doing another cleanup round right now
because there is we did get a few
garbage metrics in there over time but
not too many so oh and my favorite
the interactive graphs that you can draw
on the interface we always get those
another 300 milliseconds
so it's it's it's very snappy it's not
like you're sitting there waiting for a
graph to draw too long it's
by the time you finish typing it in and
click it usually comes right up
yes
it's whatever you set it to yeah
oh well this isn't just for mysql we
have every machine
in our production infrastructure report
to this and every machine reports more
than just
you know disk memory cpu they report
you know if you have a queuing system
they're going to report metrics out of
the queue
mysql is going to report all its status
counters and the other things we have
um we have an oracle database somewhere
that reports some oracle metrics
so there's just any any system you run
it's basically if you can
write some sort of code that will get
data that you feel is valuable that you
would consider a metric
all you have to do is print it to
standard out and you can get it into the
system
like that that's the beauty of it
so next steps i'd encourage you guys go
to try.opentsdb.net there's a
quick quick and dirty like setup there
that you can kind of poke at
i think it only has cpu information but
still it's you know an excuse to kind of
poke at the interface and see what it's
like
um go to opentsdb.net the actual page
and check out the getting started guide
and check out the overview and see what
you think of it and
maybe try pulling a copy of it and
trying it out you know you can you can
actually just
run one on your laptop real quick and
push some data into it to see what it's
like
um go to the opentsdb github
and like i said release candidate2 came
out or
2.0 release candidate came out recently
so that should be on there if it's not
the master branch they have a branch for
it
hold a copy of that and try it out see
what it's like you know look at the
information about it
and don't be afraid to contact the
authors like we all sit on freenode
all day and you know stare at each other
idling or something like that
when we're supposed to be working you
know you know how it is right freenode
and definitely i'd encourage you go to
boxes github like i said status wolf
it's i think it's our most active
project right now uh it's been getting a
lot of development and
the you know it's actually replaced
almost all the graphing and monitoring
that we have
at fox we used to have things where we'd
have cacti graphs and
a few other kind of rrd-based graphs on
different monitors
they've all been replaced with our
status wolf graphs it's
it's again it's been night and day being
able to do week over week and anomaly
detection
um based on like previous data
uh and that's it um again i work for box
we're always hiring
and if uh you're interested please come
talk to me after this presentation
and i'd like to once again thank lithium
for having us here and thank uh aaron
for getting a hold of me
to get me to speak at san francisco's my
school meet up
thanks guys
you can ask me any questions you want
i will definitely repeat the questions
for you
and then no one has questions
did you have a question yeah um
so the question was it's going to take
me a long time to get the one of the
slides i had with a cacti
screenshot of hundreds of graphs yes
that is an actual graph
i think it's fuzzy enough that you
shouldn't be able to make anything out
but it is an actual graph of
servers and it was very painful to look
at uh our knock team
really did not like it when we showed it
to them like when we finally got an off
team we're like
yeah here's cacti we're trying to get
rid of it and they're like yeah we're
no
yes
so the question is do any of our
engineers our app developers push
metrics in
and the answer is yes we actually we
worked with them to get
uh for some of our scholar services that
we have been developing
uh we had them write a connector that
plugs into the um i think it was the
koda hail metrics library
and that allows them to easily increment
counters
moving window of kind of rates on
different operations they have
and it'll automatically ship it to
opentsdb for graphing
and it's actually it's become a very
critical part of our monitoring
infrastructure
that they do that so primarily ops did
it but we also
we have our engineers doing it through
the application and there
there is um i can't remember how much
completion it had but there was a
project to have a kafka pipeline
that would do real-time analytics
through storm like it would pull them
off
pull them off the kafka pipeline and
then dump them into opentsdb
uh and so that was given us some very
valuable and interesting stuff too
so the question is do the developers
look at the graphs after they put data
in them
and the answer is definitely when
engineers roll out a new code
um or new changes they especially our we
have a dedicated performance team in our
engineering organization
they are always looking at this they're
always looking for problems and they're
always looking to see improvements
after stuff they've changed and we're
also as dbas we try to be very vocal you
know
just a few days ago an index hint was
added to a piece of code and
we had like load on our servers dropped
by significant percentage we fired an
email
and it was it was good all around you
had a question
so the question is do we have best
practices for metrics name for for
what goes into a metric name and the
tags that we use
um not really that's the thing opentsdb
grew very organically at box for
over a year um we've gotten to and
that's why i was saying we've gotten to
a point now where we're starting to pare
down and trim things down
but at a high level um we try to do it
by some sort of like service level
breakdown so
any mysql metrics are always prefixed
with mysql dot
it doesn't matter if they're a status
counter or some other thing we collect
it's always prefixed with mysql dot
hbase metrics and hadoop metrics are
prefixed with hadoop or hbase dot
excuse me um apache information from our
apache web servers apache dot
uh so on so forth and for tags
um gen so t collector will automatically
add some tags for you and you can you
can change the code to add other ones as
well
by default we have it always throw a
host tag in there which it's just kind
of a requirement you need to know what
host is sending you metrics
we also had it added an additional
metric for data center so that we can
discriminate our different data centers
when data comes in and then over beyond
that um
uh our my team the database team we
added metrics
around the database cluster the state of
the database if it's
actively serving traffic or not uh and
also its role if it's a master or slave
and so we have those automatically get
appended to any database metrics we
ship oh sure
so the question is do we allow metrics
to be automatically registered
currently we do we're going to change
that now we did
initially so that we could get more
adoption and so that people could
actually see the value in the system and
we've gotten to a point now where
we want to trim it down and it's easy
enough to add new metrics if you have it
set not to auto register them
you just have to run a command and give
it a metric name you want to add
and so we actually have a process and
puppet that
automatically does that yes
so the question is how do we handle
alerting i talked about that check
underscore tsd nagios plugin
you can use that now is your question
how do we alert off the graphs or how do
we alert about the system itself
okay to alert off the graphs check tsd
yes
so the question is have we evaluated
graphite um i haven't personally i know
two or three other people on our ops
team did and they've evaluated it two or
three times
and the last time we looked at it i
think we set it aside
for a much longer time because we have
in tstb now
um but it um i'd be interested to know
what graphite does i mean i've heard a
few people say that it doesn't scale as
well i've heard other people say it
scales very well
so i'm actually not sure yes you over
there
same question okay yes
so the question is does it hide the
complexity of hbase
or just complexity of the system itself
so i i would say
it's very easy to set this up it's very
easy to set this up on your laptop to
try it out
uh when you decide you want to actually
deploy a cluster
it's still relatively easy it's pretty
well documented
um the the people that actually set this
up didn't know that much about hbase
the people that manage it currently
because i do not manage our open ts-2b
cluster
they're more hadoop knowledgeable but
not as much hbase
but for the most part i mean running
with the default hbase setup it's been
running pretty well
we haven't had many issues and like i
said if you encounter problems you just
add more servers
but i would also say that there's a lot
of good uh
products and companies that can help you
with hbase
and i mean just off top my head cloudera
hortonworks
uh there's a few others but they have
they've open source more and more of
their tools to make managing hbase
clusters simpler so
that's definitely another starting point
to look at
come on guys give me more questions i
love answering questions yes
so what is our data retention um
so once we got our the cluster we're
currently running on set up
um i want to say we're retaining
i think about a year and a half of data
right now like i think that's the last
time we did a purge and we just we got
everything set up
correctly to support it and and we had a
plan to add more servers over time
to support the growth um
and i don't think there's plans to trim
that anytime soon but
i'm not sure
so the question is as you add more data
to opentsdb does the performance suffer
is that that right um i would say yes
unless you add more servers
um it's it's a simple thing of if you
have a mysql server and you
constantly put stuff in it there is a
point where it starts to slow down
and that is that's part of the benefit
of opentsdb by using hbase
you just stand up with some more servers
to help you know help handle the load
hbase
will automatically distribute the data
in a uniform fashion
uh and opentsdb is built in a way that
you can just add more open tsdb nodes
to tolerate any you know potential like
uh just you know
hits for that interface
so the question is can you archive data
there is there are
there are ways to the opentsdb allows
you to export the information
um and you can export it into large
files you can export it and ship it
directly to another hbase cluster if you
want
so that is an option i don't think
there's a lot of kind of automation or
pre-built tools for
easily doing that right now but i think
it's under the guise of
just keep adding servers to support your
increased load because arguably the
monitoring system is one of the most
valuable things you're going to have
and maybe you'll decide you know data
older than two years we don't care about
and that's when you do archiving
but you know that's two years from now
so you got plenty of time to figure it
out
yes
what are the specs of our servers i
think our current cluster is running on
uh super micros for our data nodes so
hbase has a notion of a master
kind of node and then a data nodes so
the data nodes are going to need to be
beefier they're going to actually be
managing all the data
um so i think we're running super micros
uh
10 one terabyte drives a piece i think
and the
the master nodes are um i think there
are 410s
you want to put more memory in your data
nodes you want your data nodes are
pretty much like a mysql server you want
a lot of memory a lot of disk
if you want to put solid states in and
you've got the money go to town
like no one's going to stop you
accept your budget maybe uh
um but does that answer your question
how many transactions do we do i
actually don't have that number i know
it's a lot more than our
customer facing clusters um i think the
last time i had looked at it it was
probably about 100 000 requests a second
how many nodes we are i think we're
running about 20 or 24 nodes
you first real quick yeah
uh so the question is this isn't the
story in the data or monitoring um
so the question is is this only for
hbase the answer is no you can
the the monitoring the collectors
um you can collect information from
anything you can collect information
about
rain in san francisco and store that in
open tsd
you can legitimately use this for any
time series data it's just gotten very
it's very popular in
the modern world for operations the back
end is hbase right now
i think there might have been a project
to make it work with statsd
or something else as a back end
somewhere but i'm not 100 sure
but the the back end is currently hbase
and the reason is because of how easy it
is to scale
is there a cassandra effort i actually
don't know um
for 2.0 there might be that that's
pretty cool i actually haven't had a
chance to use cassandra yet so
you have a question
how many unique
okay um so how the question is how does
it scale as you uh collect more metrics
uh so that's the reason we have like a
20 or 24 node cluster right now
it used to be four
and then we stood up a hundred front end
machines and that four node cluster fell
over
because our front ends report i mean
just in a minute they report two
collections of all the metrics they were
collecting
and i think they collect something like
maybe 50 to 100 metrics a minute
i know it's probably more than that i
actually can't i can't remember but it's
one of those it's
it's orders of magnitude like once you
know you look at that per minute then
you look at it over the course of a day
and then when you multiply it by the
amount of server shipping
it adds up very quickly and so you need
to it's one of those a part of your
capacity planning
when you know your new servers are
coming in you know just
based on the type of server what kind of
metrics is it going to report
and go based on that you know how much
data will you be sending
per day
can it scale up to half a million
requests per minute probably
100 million half a millimetres per
second definitely
um i know we've tolerated half a million
in in uh when we had a brief outage and
a recovery spike
so more questions guys come on
yes
the question is have we have we
considered reducing granularity we just
did last week
we turned most of our metrics down to
one minute from 30 seconds
except mysql i was not going to part
with 30 second mysql collections
much like that yeah and and
so um so one more time what was the
question
yes
so the question is have we considered
effectively downsampling our old data
um uh yeah there was an effort for that
uh it's it's been put on hold because of
other priorities but
um it is something i think that's part
of the reason we were investigating
using our kafka pipeline we had set up
to do something like that
to automatically like to submit a job
that would automatically
do some down sampling throw it into the
pipeline and then it would end up in our
cluster again
and then once we have the downsampled we
can delete them i think opentsdb 2.0
might have had some work around that to
make that a little more automated or
simple but i'm not sure i'd have to look
at the changelog again
okay well it's 8 o'clock i mean any more
questions
one last question
so the question is
so the question is can you can you
control the level of granularity for
collections
definitely and if uh if i go back to the
collector slide
it's just which if you're running t you
can create a directory
called seven and that means every seven
seconds run this collection script
um and that it'll run it every seven
seconds so you can control by
which directory you place it under t
collector
is there significant overhead against
what mysql so is there a significant
overhead against mysql if you change the
collection interval
um like i said we run it every 30
seconds without i mean
i think it's more valuable to know what
the server is doing every 30 seconds
then
five seconds um but you can do five
seconds
um you can if you want you can do one
second it's it's up to you
so yeah it's you use your judgment like
based on what information you're trying
to get out of something you know it you
know
maybe mysql you can get away with doing
a five second collection interval
um without issue you know it depends on
your workload i know for us
the the amount of data we're serving um
and the amount of buffer pool we run
with
uh collections more aggressive than 30
seconds get a little a little chubby
cool is that it you guys want me to show
you the screenshot of status buff again
because it's really cool i could go back
to it
it's somewhere
almost there
um so um our database team
uh and oh there it is cool
i just want to leave this up this is a
really cool picture yeah so initially
um my co-worker and i we had written
connector to opentsdb and our own kind
of week-over-week graphing
and then a few other people worked on it
and that you know that was one of those
things it grew organically over time and
then we also use that for our capacity
modeling kind of stuff so we have a cron
job that kicks off
once every day and another one that
kicks off every week to look at you know
do we have any auto increment counters
that are getting near a maximum value
like a max int or
a max medium enter a max big end which
if it gets too much being we're in
trouble
um do we have you know how much has our
data grown over
the past week and so we get emails about
those daily that we pull from up in tsdb
um and then this was a tool that was uh
started separately it was it was
inspired by the stuff we wrote i think
um and the the plan was to try and make
it so it was open source from the start
because we really want to contribute
something back to the community using
this tool because
one of the biggest complaints is that
the interface is very ugly
and it doesn't have some of the power
that you want it to
and in our case week over week graphs
was the biggest one
but like i said this tool has the
ability to do anomaly
kind of graphing and you can set when
you build a dashboard you can set it to
auto update on some interval
or to show you some different time span
uh for each of them
yes yes i agree the black background
makes this look
very cool and if you want you can change
the csv and make it some you know baby
blue color or something if that's
you know if that's what you want
so this tool is primarily written in php
with a lot of javascript i think a lot
of the graphing is done with d3.js
and that's the thing is opentsdb it's
just an api call effectively that hands
you back a bunch of ascii data
and you just have to tokenize it and do
what you want with it
and so we have php do that we have php
also do some caching so that this stuff
even runs even faster
but yeah